I'm McHale and with my colleague ruff oh
we're gonna present you there isn't in
enhancement that happens - and new
features in import and exporting often
language will show you how the workflows
involving the files are now even more
efficient than ever we're going to cover
richer metadata and partial access a
walk from language and last but not
least we'll talk about the recent
investments that happens to scientific
format support human language such as
speech and HDR flight
and my colleague Rafa we're gonna
present you some investments and some
new features in the import-export in the
Wolfram language and also show like
howdy you know like workflows that
involve files are now even more
efficient than they were ever we'll also
cover things like partial access and
more powerful metadata sport and last
but not least we'll talk about
enhancement that happens to such things
like scientific formats for example
feats or HDR 5 before before jumping
into that let's start from something new
which is convenience function that we
introduced in version 12 which is called
file convert so what it does it's
currently kind of a very simple function
that basically converts from one
function from from one format to another
format using the import and export
functionality in the Wolfram language
but eventually this should be a smart
enough function to do the conversion
without actually manipulative data so
finding finding out the smart ways to
convert from one format to another
format so what it is right now is
basically you you are able to convert
for example a JPEG file to a PNG file
and you will get this as a wrapped into
a file wrapper and just to show you that
as a result of conversion the results
should conform and basically there
should be no difference in the original
image that was stored in JPEG file and
the resulting image that is already a
PNG this this is the basic syntax that
is supported but there is some extension
for example you can specify the exact
file name that you want to to be
converted to or you can even specify the
format that you want to convert from it
to so for example like this JPEG file we
say that this is going from jpg to in
PNG and it doesn't really make much
sense for this particular example but
where it can be useful for example we
have we create a file and this file
contains actually a CSV data but this is
stored in a txt so we now can say okay
let's convert this txt to something else
but we know that there is a CSV data and
we actually want to have a CSV as a
result and this this will basically work
so we the new file that we get basically
is a TSV file and there are some some
options to help you to play with this
function so one of them is this create
intermediate directories it's basically
if you try to convert to a location that
doesn't really exist it will try to
create that location by default but you
may you know like specify it to be false
not to do so so basically if I try to
create something in a directory that
doesn't really exist it was not allowed
and another interesting thing is
overwrite target that you based but by
the default it will basically overwrite
the original file if it exists and
replace with a new converted one but you
still can say okay if there is something
that I already created with that name
just don't do anything so you say do not
overwrite target and it basically will
fail so and but this over a target is
kind of something new and let's
basically see what it is and I think
Rafa will basically tell you a bit more
about that right yes okay so export
would always override the destination
file right so for example if I export
hello to a text file then I export world
so if I import this file then I won't
get hello world
oh yeah I think it is but it's better
okay this I was playing this alright so
yes the export would always have the
right destination file and this isn't
the perfect solution okay I can hold the
mic alright so this isn't a perfect
solution because it's easy to accident
right if we forget that we already have
a heavy file then it would be
overwritten and also it's not possible
to perform a complex multi-step export
right so for example for a gif file
where there are multiple frames it makes
sense to be able to export frames
separately right so so that we can
append new frames at the end of the gif
file right now this is not possible so
that's why I have introduced a new
option to export all right target and
there are three possible values for
overwrite target the first one is true
so this is the default value because we
want to be backwards compatible so and
this corresponds to the current behavior
but now we can also specify false so
first if the destination file does not
exist it will be created and then if you
try to export something else you will
get a an error message okay and the last
possible value for override target is
append so this is not supported by all
formats right not not in every format it
makes sense to append data but one file
format that supports it is hdf5 so in
this example we first export two groups
to an HD f5 file right well there's also
the route group which is always there
and then we want to add a new group to
the existing file group C so we use this
overwrite target a pen right
scroll that yes so now you can see that
we have a new group and those that were
there before okay so this is overwrite
target let's not let's not talk about an
update to impart namely partial access
so imagine you have a very large set of
data and you want to access only a small
part of it so it does not make sense to
import everything into memory and then
extract but it's better to just import
specific part from the file here we have
a CSV file and we can say that we want
data and let that just import every
third call every third row starting from
the second one and up to 12 right so
this will import exactly what we
requested and you can see here that I
can basically achieve the same thing by
first loading everything and then doing
part right yeah so the result is the
same but for large file you will for
watch files will notice the difference
in speed right so we can go even further
and first specify the rows and then
columns from a CSV file right so this
will import on the contents of the
second column in those rocks right so
you can see that this actually okay and
for CSV and Excel and this topic will be
covered in details bye-bye Shawn in his
talk which is right after this one all
right and we have another way of doing
partial access so you may have you may
have a large piece of data in your file
and then a small pieces of metadata so
again it it makes sense to be able to
import this metadata very quickly while
loading the whole file for example I
have this two gigabytes hdf5 file yes
with plenty of real numbers but you can
see that if I want to import just a list
of data sets it happens instantly
right the same for the data format all
right so let's talk a bit more about
partial accessing like in case of hdf5
because in general our ultimate goal is
to have a consistent syntax for all
formats to do partial access efficiently
but right now for hdf5 this syntax a bit
different we have a option called take
elements and for example let's work with
this fire yes so we export a matrix that
looks like this so there are three ways
to access specific parts of this data
setting hdf5
so you may give it a list of positions
right so for example let's say I want to
only import so one one and two three
which is this one it looks like this and
I get 1 comma 5 so this works and it
actually works pretty fast let's do a
test on this two gigabytes file that I
had on a previous slide so now if I use
take elements to to import just like
five points from this very large file it
happens instantly so the second number
is the number of bytes in the memory
that were used and just to compare it
let's import everything and then use the
built-in function extract to get the
same points and you may see that it's
like two orders of magnitude slower okay
another way to do partial axis negative
five is to specify spans so this is
quite similar to what I showed for CSV
so here you see that here you say that
you want rows from the second to fourth
and columns three to six and if I'm not
mistaking this should be exactly this
rectangle here let's see right okay and
the last thing is that just syntax
possible is that you can use those four
sub elements this is a native way of
doing
accessing in hdf5 well instead of
describing let me just show an example
so imagine this grid is a data set each
data so and the blue region is what
we'll actually import right which which
data elements so offset means where do
we want to start importing because it
doesn't have to be at the beginning then
we of course may want to import many
data elements but it doesn't have to be
a contiguous region so we may want to
have gaps right so this is tried and up
to this point it can be achieved using
those spans syntax but now let's see
that let's say that we don't want to
import just one cell in every block yes
we can import more more cells right so
something like this quite complex it can
be achieved using this last syntax okay
so this is partial access maybe five but
the other new other new elements so in
export you can now export data sets so
these are just containers with data you
can either give it just data or data
plus some metadata right and this is
imported back you can export groups I
will just give it a group name or you
may have groups with some links okay and
you can import the file as a graft to
see its structure and you can see the
three groups we export it and those
links that we defined here another new
element in export is named data types so
we can basically have an information
about some type either very simple like
an signed integer 16 or something more
complex and you can save it to a file
and then import it back okay in the last
new export element is attributes so
every object in India file and may carry
attributes
so these are basically pairs like a name
and the value which can be of any type
here's a string here is a byte array
okay and we can import that back all
right
so apart from export elements we now
support more data types
so we already supported integer and real
numbers now we have complex numbers
although they are not natively supported
in hd5 we have an option called complex
keys so that you can help export to how
to save them and the data in the file
and then we can import this back as
complex numbers right so this is the
data we export it and the type and also
now we correctly support utf-8 strings
there is also another new type
it's called opaque in hdf5 and this can
be used for data that does not have any
predefined meaning so this basically
corresponds to byte array in one
language as for example here I have a
hash of some string which I exported
that I can import it back as a byte
array okay and the last one the most
complex type is called compound so this
is like a map of key value pairs pairs
and this corresponds to an association
in hdf5
so the values can be of different types
here like a list of integers string or
you can have nested associations all
right and you can see that we can import
it back from the file okay
another new thing in 85 is a new option
append mode this is basically an
extension of this overwrite target that
I talked about earlier so now if you
export some data to an 85 file like a
data set group and attribute you have
now free a possible ways of appending
new things to this file
the default one is extent so you can add
new datasets to the file you can add new
features to existing objects for example
new links in the group and as you can
see we added a new dataset and a new
link so then if you want to modify
existing features of existing objects
then you have to use overwrite so now
you can take this link gr1 and redirect
it to a different object in the file and
this will completely change the
structure of the file so you have to be
careful you could also overwrite the
data in the datasets data format and
dimensions match right so I have a data
set of a list of 10 integers I can
basically overwrite the same and there
is also less possible append mode this
is the safest one preserved so here you
can only add new objects to the file but
you cannot touch anything that already
exists in the file right so I can add
new data set but this should trigger a a
message see right ok so I cannot modify
the existing group but I was able to add
a new data set all right and there's
also one last update hd5 so now we
directly support numeric arrays in hd5
so in numeric array is a new container
that we introduced in version 12 it's
basically more memory very memory
efficient version of packet array so
just to show you the difference if we
have a million integers in a list it
takes 8 million bytes but with numeric
array if we say that those integers are
all quite small and they will fit in 8a
if it bites then you can see that it
takes less space all right so let's
define such a numeric array and
basically there will be a separate table
devoted to numeric arrays
it's 2:30 p.m. I really recommend and
let's talk okay but the HD 5 you can see
that I can directly put in America array
in export it will be exported then I can
import it back here you can see that the
type of data is actually taken as this
one alright so as for import we have a
new import element raw data that it will
everything that is possible will be
imported as numeric array for efficiency
reasons so let's just quickly compare
the timings you can see that if you can
live with numeric array then it will be
imported much much faster and also the
smaller memory footprint ok so these are
all the updates HD 5 and now let's talk
about fits
okay so fit is another scientific format
that we support and we we did introduced
this earlier so this is not new in 12
but there are some kind of important
highlights that I would like to talk
about so first of all one one thing that
is new is now that everything is
returned in form of associations even if
you have a single HD a file which was
not the case before and even if you
specify you know that you want to import
specific header here even in this case
this is going to be Association and this
is kind of very useful thing because
when you say you have multi header file
and you want to import on the English
data the you know distribution of the
heaters containing English data can be
not continuous and you may get you know
like first like thousands and five
thousandth our images
and if you get it back as you know like
Ness at least it's kind of hard to
figure out who is who and this way you
always know which either is
correspondent to which part of the data
that you imported another thing is that
we have basically changed the default
behavior of an option that was supported
which is include extensions and
basically what what is it was before it
was importing everything everything that
is present in the file and now it
imports whatever is related to the data
that is requested so for example if you
ask for table data and this is the
default behavior now so the second
hitter of this file contains the table
data and that's important so you can see
the first key in this association while
you still can trigger the legacy
behavior by specifying include extension
so and of course the same things that
were supported like list of strings as a
value for include extensions still
support and I think as Rafa said for
example for hdf5 the raw data this is
very very valid for fits as well so we
have numeric arrays a numeric or a
support for image data because it
doesn't really make sense for table
tabular data of infants and this is very
well supported in export and export of
hits as well I'm running a bit of
opt-out of times that's why I'm going
this quick so the other thing is that
people who were more or less familiar
with feeds may know that binary tables
are kind of very complex structure in
States and they are always
two-dimensional but each cell can be
multi-dimensional and we did support
import for that type of binary tables
but now we also do have support for
export of that type of tables which
opens up you know like application
possible applications for this case I
will show one at the end
and of course partial access is very
well supported for fits as well so what
we had for example this header
specification before what we added
basically really the full support that
is supported for by part the
the same syntax is supported for partial
access here so you can basically use
past lists and so on okay so besides
besides being able to specify the header
you are also able to specify partial
access for the actual data so that's
this is how it works and the beauty of
partial access if it is that in image
[ __ ] you may have you know like
raise up to 999 dimensions and this is a
way basically not to deal with all that
all of that memory and if you know what
exactly you are looking for you can
easily get that back of course this is
efficient of course this is this
consumes less memory I mean even for
this smile that is really small you can
see the difference both in timing and
the memory consumption so this really
makes sense and as I promised the
application that okay so we we I can say
that we have kind of complete support
for Fitz and this opens up a lot of
possibilities to create you know like
real life working application examples
so for example this is one thing that I
have prepared for today so you basically
are able to select the directory where
you have all of your files that you're
interested in and load them to the
memory and basically you have this type
of list here basically which which
contains all the file names you what
you're looking into and for example you
can click on any of them and on the
right panel you will see the detailed
header information and also the data and
for multi-table
let me see okay so for example here we
have two aged use here and you can
basically trigger between each of the HD
use and both image and table data
present here and what else you can do is
basically you since like you may want to
use this in another application for
example you may trigger a download to
basically convert this to more widely
used formats and download this file for
example I can do this on my desktop and
you will see that this file for example
is or should okay yeah so okay so
basically
it's converted to tiff so this TIFF
contains now the actual image what was
stored in the fades and and basically
the meta information is stored in XML so
looking up this XML doesn't really make
much sense here so but this is how it
looks and you can basically inverse this
back to Mathematica and another cool
thing that you have here is that
basically you are able to do really
quick search which is basically almost
instant is say for example you can
basically search for all the files that
you have that are the own that the
organization that made that file for
example here so and basic I may not have
that ok but ok maybe we can find the
ones that start with M or the object
that contains okay so this file contains
an object to that that start with M and
you basically have this is just you know
like demonstration application you may
enhance in whatever range and the
purpose of this is to show that the the
support is full enough to to do any real
real-life application with Mathematica
now ok so where is that
and let's basically eat so if you have
any questions I think we can answer them
in that mean
meanwhile the the next speaker comes to
otherwise yeah